I gotta file this now a little bit did I
have to the dehumidifiers it
Oh I'm shooting a video I'm already
recording what was this about again
[Applause]
[Music]
happy world mental health day so this is
a video that I had been planning to do
in some capacity for a while and you're
actually getting an extra video this
week because I wanted to release it on
the day now World Mental Health Day to
me gave me I think the opportunity to
talk about my own mental health and the
thing is what I'm gonna talk about well
you'll know from the title what it
already is so I'm not gonna play coy
about it but I think a lot of times when
people on YouTube talk about their
mental health it usually means some form
of depression or anxiety or in the case
of lgbtq+ people it is often linked to
dysphoria none of which are conditions I
have so a DD feels and I did actually
for for a brief time debate on whether
or not to make this cuz it feels like
such an innocuous condition versus a lot
of the stuff people talk about when they
talk about mental health but it's also
my reality it's what I live with it's
what I've been living with her my life
and it does impact my life the way I
live and I think I've found when I've
talked about other things about myself
here or on the veer a wild channel that
I see more than enough comments
basically saying wow that's kind of like
me but no one else ever talks about it
that make me think maybe there's some
value in me talking about this so you
know maybe you'll
here's something that rings a bell or
maybe you'll just get a slightly better
understanding of a DD who knows or maybe
I'll just waste your time for however
long I go on talking I tend to do that
too so attention deficit disorder I
notice I'm not actually talking about
ADHD which is the tension deficit
hyperactive disorder cuz I don't have
that I've never had hyperactivity as a
component of my a DD it is just the
attention deficit so if you are
wondering about that end of things I
can't help you at least not as far as my
own personal experience goes but what
does it mean to have attention deficit
disorder move what you can't focus just
try harder yeah that that's not how it
works that's like telling you a
depressed person oh stop it just be
happy huh so attention deficit disorder
basically means that it is difficult for
me to filter out information and input
in order to better focus on something
more closely with more attention and in
more detail it's very easy for me to get
distracted not like necessarily on my
own it's not like I have no it's not
that it's not necessarily a lack of an
attention span it is a difficulty in
blocking out other stuff so like in some
practical terms it is very hard for me
to watch something at home a movie Usher
or whatever and not have my phone in my
hand because like look if you've got a
GED the internet and smartphones effect
is said especially I can talk are crack
because there's always something else
you can be doing and that feeds a DD
like you would not believe this idea
that okay I'm doing this but I also
could be doing all this other stuff oh
let me just hop onto this oh this
oh this oh this oh this ain't just then
four hours are gone so that means that
for me
pop probably more so than other people
it is optimal if I'm gonna see a movie
to see it in a theater because my phone
is turned off
it's dark the only thing I can see well
is the screen there's no ambient noise
there's the background noise it cuts out
all the distractions in a way that most
people to some extent can do on their
own
when you have a Dede you really can't do
that it's actually one of the things
that makes things difficult for me going
out to clubs or bars or raucous parties
or anything like where there's loud
music it's really difficult for me
because and in like there was a it's so
bad that there was a time that I thought
something was wrong with my hearing
until I actually went no it's because of
my AADD we're like a really hard time
hearing people in those sorts of loud
busy environments but it's not because I
can't hear them my hearings fine has
been tested repeatedly it's because I
can't filter out all the other input
well enough to truly zero in and hear
what someone's talking to me I have to
be like right up to them because I just
I can't filter the input it's not to say
that I can't filter at all I can't it's
just I I can't do it as well I can't do
it as well as the majority of the
population most people can fade the
music down and down into the background
zero in on the person they're talking to
I I can't like imagine you've got if
you've got music on it's too loud for
you to properly hear the person imagine
trying to turn it down but it only turns
down a little bit like you can't turn it
down as much as you actually need to
that's what it's like so it's also worth
pointing out a JD is one of those
conditions where a bit like OCD where a
lot of people go
oh I've so got that and they don't they
just have a pattern of behavior they
don't actually have a diagnosis so I do
want to emphasize I have been formerly
daya formally diagnosed with a DD and
that happened to me when I was in
seventh grade I believe right so around
about 13 and I know there's always this
concern like Oh parents just want an
excuse to medicate their kids well I
mean my mother fought really hard to not
have me go on medication she didn't want
me to have to do that and she wanted to
be dang certain that this was what was
going on because I was having some
troubles at school I was having some
difficulty with some things and it was
actually suggested to her by my math
teacher at the time because his son who
was older than me he had been diagnosed
with a DD and he was seeing some of the
same stuff in me that had gone on with
his son so he talked to my mother about
it my mother took me to get tested on
this this was like a whole afternoon of
various tests this was fairly extensive
and by the end of it they did determine
again no hyperactivity issues but I do
have attention deficit and initially she
tried you know alternate things like you
know herbal and whatnot and they didn't
help and I was put on ritalin through
high school which is another thing that
should be addressed because armchair
pharmacologists who don't really know
what they're talking about
well sometimes bring up this idea of
well ad D that's all kinds of messed up
because they put them on Ritalin ritalin
czar stimulant why would you give a
stimulant to someone who can't focus and
it might be hyperactive yes ritalin is a
stimulant but because the brain
chemistry of someone with a DD or ADHD
is not the same as a normal person it
doesn't affect us the way that it would
you riddle into someone who doesn't have
a DD is basically like speed but if you
have a DD that's not what it does to you
it just gives you that ability to filter
and zoom in and focus better and again
talking about the focus I am perfectly
capable of focusing on stuff that I care
about I mean god I have to be the
schedule I keep on this freakin thing
but it's really really hard for me to
maintain a focus on something that I do
not have an inherent you interested it
is hard for me to brute-force my way
into paying attention to something and
that has been something that I've had to
deal with for a long time and I've lived
both on and off medication I was on
medication through high school I tried a
different medication in college didn't
take it consistently was probably a
contributing factor to why I didn't
finish college definitely not the only
factor I had a lot of stuff going on
that did not help the situation I went
off medication for well probably about a
decade and I saw the difference I felt
the difference I could tell the
difference
but for about a decade I was in a work
and life situation where I knew enough
about what I could do or didn't do well
and with the job I had at the time and
how life was going at the time I was
functioning okay I was I mean I was
functioning fine I am on medication for
my a D D again but it's because I was
trying I was trying to focus on things
and knowing that I need help it's like
trying to walk and going like I can't
just make this limp go away I'll use a
cane or I'll get a brace or something
it's okay to admit that for what you're
trying to do you need the assistance and
I hit a point again where I really did
and maybe I will hit a point where I
don't again and how I know how to
function off of medication will work
just fine for me but that's some where I
am right now so I am currently medicated
and it it is helpful so some of the
practical upshots besides some of the
stuff that I've talked about already
with a DD this is part of why I do
YouTube the way that I do because it's
much harder for me to do things like
what Lindsey Ellis does what Dan Olson
does what Patrick Williams Natalie win
h-bomb ERG are all these youtubers who
do work that I think is amazing it's
really hard for me to do something like
what they do because there's a reason
most of those channels and others like
them only put out one video a month on
average because they sync a lot of time
into it a lot of times scripting a lot
of time shooting a ton of time editing
and it's very difficult for me to
maintain momentum on something long-term
I am capable of it for crying out loud
I've I've written a book I've written a
play written a novel that I'm working on
trying to get in a publishable state
right now so I can do it but the reason
that I've fallen into the pattern of
doing YouTube the way that I do it which
is to sit down in front of a camera
ramble on for between 15 and 20 minutes
and then throw it together with very few
edits is because it allows me with
basically in the course of one evening
to come away with a finished product
which works with my a DD much better
than trying to take something that is
going to take weeks or months to work on
and working on it a little bit at a time
that frustrates my
my headspace because I'm just looking at
this longingly I'm like oh my god I'm
gonna be doing this forever
but if I do something like an overdue
Doctor Who review I sit down I watch
whatever episode it is I get into what
I'm gonna wear for it shoot the video
one take if I do a good job at it I
don't stumble anywhere and I'd so I
don't need to cut anything out slap it
into my editing software add maybe one
or two visual references for specific
things that I mentioned set it to render
and I'm done in one evening I have a
finished video is it the best that it
could possibly be
could it be better with a ton more
possible yes but I'm probably always
even if please I ever get to the point
where this is my living and I start
doing bigger projects like some of the
people who I mentioned because I really
would like to it's just hard when I'm
also holding down a full-time job
but even if I start doing that I don't
see myself ever stopping doing the quick
turnaround stuff because the quick
turnaround energizes me and inherently
plays and feeds into just how my brain
works if I can go in do something and
then for about as long as I'm able to
properly focus on that thing which
depending on what it is maybe if human
is there maybe a few hours if at the
point that I'm done if I can come away
and go huh I made a thing nice whereas
if I spend four hours ago huh I made a
12th of a thing that's just
disheartening and part of the reason is
because I I bow
so much and came and feel like I came
away with so little so the fact that I
have a DD is actually a massive
influence on how I even approach this
platform and maybe it's not the ideal
way to approach this platform I'm pretty
sure if my eyes were completely on
maximizing my subscribers and my views
or whatever else I would be doing this
differently than the way I do but then I
would be battling against myself my
brain my a DD as opposed to working with
it which is what I do and I'm happier
for it so that's a nice unscripted semi
intelligible ramble about how living
with a DD affects me my life and maybe
it's some insight for you maybe it's
something you can relate to or maybe I
just wasted probably gonna end up being
about eighteen minutes which was it you
decide so in any case
happy world mental health day good
health to you if you need help I hope
you have it if you need to get it I hope
you do and if you don't need help
because you're doing okay or you already
have the help you need that's awesome
too
so whatever your thoughts are on this
drop them down in the comments let's
talk about a whole bunch of stuff to do
buttons links like subscribe leave a
comment 'i'd helped me out on my patreon
that would be much appreciated you want
the bigger and better projects you know
just saying daddy get me there
even a dollar a month seriously it does
help every little drop in the bucket and
eventually the bucket will overflow
there's all their links down to stuff
down there besides not all of it is me
asking for money so click around check
things out or don't it's alright if you
don't cuz at the end of the day you're
the council
I'm just fronting the meetings and until
next time something something I can't
remember I got a mess around on my phone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]